《红楼梦》第34回,贾宝玉被父亲贾正打得我闯不起。心中又签掛着林黛玉,想要派人去消相馆打探一番,但他似乎鸡鱼某种顾虑故意前走了习人,却就来了秦文去看这件事,援助记。
宝玉因心下激挂着待遇,满心里要打发人去,只是怕习人,便设一法,先使习人往宝餐那里去借书。习人去了,宝玉便命秦文来,吩咐到,你到林姑娘那里看看她做什么呢,她要问我,只说我好了。
操绝今此处写的云山物赵,贾宝玉为什么怕习人,又为什么选择让秦文去消相馆。由于独者阅独视野的受限,面对这类情节,往往会采取主观猜测的途径进行解读。
比如有相当一部分独者认为,习人是王夫人的应权,贾宝玉的任何信息都会被泄密,所以宝玉得防着习人,秦文则是贾宝玉的自己人,所以才放心把探房消相馆的任务交给她。
立足援助文本,习人与第三十六回才被内定为准一娘,之前王夫人对习人并不亲近,故而,第三十四回,习人向王夫人提见一时,王夫人曾说,进来我应听见众人,背前背后都夸你,我只说你不过是在宝玉身上流星,或是诸人跟前合气,这些小意思好,谁知你方才和我说的话,
全是大道理,正和我的想头一样。足可见在此之前,王夫人只是将习人当成一个,具有温柔和气优点的普通压缓,并不觉得他有什么特殊。
独者认为,习人来王夫人亲信是立足后文而言,而以后文正前文,进乎马后炮,这样的解读显然是没有道理的,也难以令独者幸福。
至于家宝玉选择秦文去传信,也并不是独者所议测的秦文是宝玉亲信。
蒙夫本此处批语写的是,秦文秦文放肆原有拔饼所试言,意思是,之前秦文摔坏善谷无理取闹,记得家宝玉差点把秦文年走,
最后是习人求秦,待遇做课,打断了这场吵闹,秦文放肆的马饼该有此生。
但不宏今思认为,这处批语也不一定准确,因为摔扇风波之后,紧接着就是思善子做亲近一笑。
家宝玉和秦文的关系早已得到缓和,若真如批读人所言,其不成了家宝玉以把饼邀写秦文,
这恐怕不符合曹宫的本意,在此基础上,我们回过头来看开篇提出的那个问题,
家宝玉为何选择秦文去销乡馆,而害怕习人知晓,答案其实很简单,
习人知道家宝玉去销乡馆的真实意图,秦文却不知道,故而原著中,
秦文给林代玉送完两块就手怕之后,回来的路上一路盘算不解合意,
家宝玉要的就是秦文的不解奇,家宝玉之所以要瞒着习人,
是因为第三十二回,曾发生了宿废府新迷火宝玉的情节,
家宝玉向林代玉告白,误打误撞,被钱来送善子的习人给听到了,
这就成了后文很多情节的导火锁。
宝玉出了神,见习人和她说话,并未看出是何人来,便一把拉住,说道,
好妹妹,我的这心事从来也不敢说,
今日我大胆说出来,死也甘心,
我为你也弄了一生的病在这里,又不敢告诉人,只好眼着,
只等你的病好了,只怕我的病才得好呢,
睡里梦里也忘不了你。
习人听了这话,吓得破销魂散,只叫神天菩萨,坑死我了,
便推她倒,这是哪里的话,敢是中了邪,还不快去。
宝玉意识醒过来,方知是习人送善子来,
修的满面子账,夺了善子,便茫茫地抽身跑了。
基于时代背景的原因,我等独者很容易忽视这段描写的严重性,
觉得不过就是假宝玉,像林代玉,苏说真心,没什么大不了,
可在红龙梦的背景年代里,一南一女与月父母之命,
思乡传递爱意,这是绝对不允许的。
尤其假宝玉的这段表白,已经完全不能解释为哥哥对妹妹的关心,
而是彻彻底底的男女之爱。
故而习人听见后,吓得魂销破散,这一点也不夸张。
更要命的是,一旦这种是流传出去,将会对保代的名声造成毁灭性打击。
所以原住里,习人在家宝与离开后,一个人带力原地进留下类来,心中想到。
自私方才之言,一定是因代玉而起,如此看来,将来难免不才之时,令人可惊可未。
想到此间,也不觉争争的低下类来,心中暗夺,如何处置方免此丑获。
草绝情对苏废府一捷的描述点到为止,没有摊开来讲,独者也几乎忘记了这件事的严重。
而事实上,家宝与之后见到习人,心中多多少少有点尴尬和担忧。
于是呼,家宝与派人去消相馆,之所以不让习人去,就是因为习人早已知晓了内情。
家宝与任何举动下的心思,根本瞒不过他,习人会清楚地知道,宝与是想念待遇了。
这种想念的背后,是不被社会所允许的爱情在作碎。
反观秦文,他就拆不透家宝与的心思。
宝与让秦文去消相馆看看,秦文觉得无视不当三宝店,自己莫名其妙去消相馆十分变扭。
家宝与就随手拿了两块就手怕,让他当个送物人。
秦文又觉得林代玉怎么会吸汗这种就手怕,而如果换成习人,根本不用家宝与都说一句话,他立刻就能知晓宝与的真实想法,而这种真实想法是见不得光的,习人也不会赞同。
所以只能让什么都拆不出的秦文去,从这个角度来看,习人后来向王夫人提建议,一方面是因为宝与哀了吃看,
另一方面也有对宿废腐这件事的忌惮,所以习人希望家宝与搬处大官员,以物理距离的方式,避免不才知识发生的可能性。
如此一关,独动红楼秦节经常需要久连环思维。
从宿废腐新迷火宝与,秦中秦因秦感妹妹,到习人向王夫人提建议,秦文给代预送就怕,
再到王夫人内定习人为准一鸟,这中间的故事线索非常紧密。
一旦缺乏对红楼文本秦节的深刻动查,就会陷入世景阴谋解读的选与,
延伸出主观误读,这是每一位红楼阅读者,都需要格外注意的。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。